- [Kris] Great.
Great that you're all here.
So, I hope you're all excited to be here.
And I hope you're excited to learn
about all the new products
and services and features
and all that here at reInvent.
Is anyone excited?
I saw you could raise your hands.
I saw that earlier.
Yeah, there you go.
That's one.
And tell me again.
Just, no, indeed, raise those arms.
You're going to be doing this
a lot of times this week.
But who here is excited
to use those new services,
and features when they get back home
or back at the office, of course?
But who of you also has some
rework that needs to get done?
So, who here has a backlog,
who'd like to use those
services, but still,
there's something to do?
There you go.
All right.
This is Matteo Palazzi,
and I'm Kris Nielander.
No, I'm sorry about that.
We're professional services consultants
for AWS Professional Services.
And as consultants, we're
working on the clock.
And we need to get things
right the first time,
every time, quality, security.
But it's not only us.
It's the team as well.
So, it's partners.
It's customers.
It's you.
And today, we're going
to show you how we do
and how you can accelerate
your code delivery
by using development containers
with Amazon AI Code Assistant.
But before we get into
that, I just want to know.
So, are there any other
consultants here as well?
No?
Engineers?
- One.
- Oh, one.
Okay.
We've got some engineers as well.
Have we got my security people as well?
Ah, yeah.
Wonderful, wonderful.
But actually, a more important question.
Is there anyone here already
using development containers?
Ah, good, good, good.
Well, no worries.
We'll go through the basics as well.
So, everyone's on the same page.
One final remark.
This is a code talk.
And I don't know if you've
done a code talk before,
if you've attended one.
But it's like a long live demo.
So, we'll be doing coding
and stuff like that.
And hopefully, you'll enjoy it.
But it's also interactive.
So, if you do have a question,
we'll try to pause every now
and then so you can pop one in.
And if we can't answer it,
then you can approach us afterwards.
That's also fine.
Cool.
All right.
First thing, I really want to make sure
we're all on the same page here.
So let me set the stage.
So, I want you to imagine
that it's Monday morning,
maybe the Monday after reInvent.
And indeed, you're excited to get to work
to try those new services and features.
But remember that pull request
you had from last week?
Yeah, it got rejected.
And as you're getting ready
to fix it, to mend it,
now you have security
reaching out over Slack
that they found an
overly permissive bucket.
And you need to drop
everything and fix it?
All right.
Now it's Thursday.
And you're everyone's hero.
You mended your PR.
You fixed the bucket.
But it is Thursday already.
And your sprint commitments
are in serious jeopardy.
Does that sound plausible?
I see some nodding heads.
That's good.
And it should, because 45%
of production deployments
actually require rework.
It's even higher.
But I'll get to that in a little bit.
Or rollbacks.
And about that open S3 bucket,
so we still have the
broken access controls
on the OAuth top 10 at number one.
Mind you, security
misconfigurations is at two.
So, we're doing exceptionally well.
But if you think you've
got everything tied down,
your buckets are all
locked up, collectively,
we pushed over 23 million secrets
onto public GitHub repositories
over last year alone.
We're not doing that well
with private repositories
as well, so yeah.
All right.
Now, where do we want to be?
So, imagine again that it's
that same Monday morning.
But this time, you're
starting on a new project.
And you're already delivering
your first meaningful commit
that very same morning.
No extensive rework.
No security people knocking on your door.
No onboarding issues.
No runtime issues.
That's where we want to be, right?
Sounds ideal.
We want to be one of those
elite engineering teams.
All right.
But what does that actually mean?
So, I've got some numbers for you.
Is anyone here familiar with Dora?
I'm not talking about the little girl
with the monkey in the boots, right?
I'm also not talking about some
European legislative piece,
right, for you security people.
Now, this is a long-running
research program from Google
about operational excellence
in software delivery.
And so, this is a survey.
It's been running for 10 years already.
And since I have you all here,
we can kind of repeat the survey.
So, I'll ask you about the first category.
That's a change lead time.
That's how long it takes
for a commit to go all
the way into production.
So, I want to ask you to
raise your hands again
and tell me, how long
does it take your teams?
Months?
From a commit all the way to production?
No?
Are you all good?
- Sometimes.
There you go.
All right.
Weeks?
Yeah, that's more realistic, right?
Is there anyone who can just
pull this off within a day?
- [Member] Sometimes.
- [Kris] Oh, you're elite, mate.
You should be up there.
We should be there.
Right.
No, but that is indeed how it is.
We have the elite teams
taking under a day to do this,
then moving towards the low performance,
taking weeks up to months.
I'm sorry, mate.
But we get to improve.
That's why you're here, right?
All right, second thing
is deployment frequency.
This is how often you would
actually deploy to production.
So, are we talking about
once every few months again?
I would expect the same hands.
There you go.
Once every few weeks?
Yeah.
All right.
So, we got the elite teams
here just doing it on demand.
Whenever you need it,
push there to production.
And by the way, why is
this metric important?
And this is one which is
important also with regards to AI.
This is talking about how small
your commits actually are.
Like, the smaller the
commit, the lower the risk,
the less impact on production.
And the funny thing is, with AI,
you usually make very large commits.
Cool.
I'll spare you the other
metrics for the survey.
But I'll tell you the
field deployment recovery.
So, this is how long it
will actually take you to go
from that bad situation onto
a normal operation again.
And you have the elites typically
taking upwards of a day,
where the low performers
taking maybe days to weeks
to months just to restore a service.
And this is, of course, impacting
your customer experience.
And the last bit, the change fail rate,
that's actually the metric
I had on the other slide.
So, it's 45% to 60% of all
those production deployments
either require rework or rollbacks.
That's pretty significant.
And you have the elite
teams typically around 15%.
So, all right.
That's nice numbers, right?
So how do we get there?
So, this is where dev containers
help remove the potholes
to actually make you go fast.
They enable you to create
a consistent development environment
with embedded quality
controls, with security checks,
like having your static analysis tools.
You've got your linters
that you can integrate.
You've got your code
formatters, your scanners.
All that can be integrated
within your dev container.
But it's also the tool
to quickly help you adopt
other tools, like Amazon Q Developer.
And that helps accelerate your teams.
It accelerates your onboarding.
One final note on this, though,
and if you read the Dora reports,
they'll tell you there
is no silver bullet,
which will improve everything.
But dev containers will
definitely help you
unlock those elite practices.
So, that's how you should view this.
All right, and that's what
we're going to talk about today.
We're going to talk
about how we can use those dev containers
to actually make our AWS
projects, our deployments,
all the better, and just
accelerate those deployments.
And on the first bit,
Matteo is going to explain a little bit
about the anatomy of a dev container.
So, what are the key components there?
How is the configuration built up?
In the second bit, he's going to talk
about how you can integrate
Amazon Q, Q Developer,
inside a dev container configuration
and enable these complex workflows,
which go over the rule-based stuff,
which is usually in your
static analysis tools.
The third bit is, because
we also want to scale,
we want to enable some
kind of modular system
within those development containers.
And luckily, there's
development container features,
which are like these
repeatable building blocks.
So instead of adopting
it just for one image,
you can use it for the
other, and for the other,
and for the other, right?
Now, to scale even
further, we'll also talk
about creating a pipeline for
these development containers.
So, it's no longer just you building it
on your local laptop.
It's building it inside a pipeline
and to make sure these
images are available,
images and features, for
anyone who needs them.
And before I hand over the
floor to Matteo, again,
I'd like to remind you,
it's an interactive session.
So, if you do have a
question for us, pop one in.
Matteo?
- [Matteo] Thank you, Kris.
So, as you very well said,
we as consultants need
to be right the first time, all the times.
And this means that we
need to take care about
all the little problems,
all the little bits,
before creating an artifact
for our customers, right?
This means that we might
want to discover all
of the problems before
a CICD pipeline starts
and find that, right?
So, it means that we want
to shift left all the checks
into our development environment.
So, what do we have here today?
So here I have Visual Studio Code, right?
Are you familiar with that?
I think so.
But how do we do shift left these checks?
So, we use, it's pretty easy, right?
Use dev containers.
So, we create dev containers
to standardize our development
environment across developers
in the team, across teams,
so we all get the same environment, okay?
What is a dev container?
You can guess it.
It's a container, right?
So as a container, we need
two main things to use it.
One is the container runtime.
You can use Docker.
You can use Phinch.
You can use Rancher.
You can use whatever
container runtime you prefer.
And the second thing is
an IDE that is compatible
with dev containers,
like VS Code, IntelliJ,
and many others.
So, let's get into the demo.
We have here a CDK application, right?
You might be familiar with that.
It doesn't matter, right?
It's not the scope of the session today.
We're not going to say how CDK works,
how to deploy a stack with CDK.
Doesn't matter.
Just let's take it as a Python code.
We want to create the environment
to be effective developing
Python code, right, in this case.
To do that, we need to
create a dev container.
And the dev container needs to be inside.
The dev container configuration needs
to be inside a specific path.
It needs to be inside
.devcontainer/devcontainer.json, right?
That's the config file.
And the config file could be very easy
or a bit more complex.
In this case, you see that
there is only one line.
It's quite easy, right?
So, this is the image that
the container runtime will use
to create a container that
the IDE will be connecting to.
As you see on the screen,
there are also other lines commented out.
And let's go through them quickly.
So, the first one is one
example of a lifecycle command.
With dev containers, we
can use lifecycle events.
It means that we can
run commands, scripts,
based on the lifecycle event,
which means, for example,
when you create a container,
after the creation,
it's run a command.
When you attach to the container,
which is similar to
when you open the laptop
in the morning and you start developing,
so you attach to the
development environment,
it might run another set of commands.
Then you can also configure
your IDE setting, for example,
the tab size in this example,
or maybe installing some extensions.
Lastly, we can add features.
We will talk about features
in more details later
during the session.
But in this case,
I want to show you
how easy it is to create the container.
So, we have this configuration file.
And then we just reopen in container.
And it will detect that
the dev container JSON file is there.
It will read it.
And it will create a
container that the IDE
will be connecting to.
As you see here, I'm running on a Mac.
And if I run here
at uname-a, I'm in Linux.
This is because I'm running
inside the dev container.
But, you know,
this is a very basic image.
We want to have an effective
environment to develop.
So, I've prepared another example.
As I said before, the
dev container JSON file
might be a bit complex.
So, in this example,
it is a bit more complex.
Instead of using a single image,
I'm referring to a Docker file inside
the dev container directory.
It's important.
That Docker file is going to
build an image locally, okay.
As we are talking about
a Python application,
we need the Python VM.
And the Python VM is based on the host
that you are running on.
So, for example, if I create
the Python VM on Mac OS,
it's going to be different from the one
that is going to be created on Linux.
So, we want to create a VM all the times
that we create the new container.
Because otherwise, when
you clone the repo inside
the container,
it might have a different
virtual environment.
And it could not work.
The other things that we are
adding here are pip audit
and pip licenses as part
of our security guidelines.
And we run those commands
when we open our laptop,
so when we connect to the container.
I'm also adding some
configurations for the IDE.
So, for example, I'm defining
the Python default formatter
to black formatter that
is going to be installed
as an extension together
with pylint and flakate.
Of course, you can add all
the extensions you want.
You can add formatters, linters,
all the security tools you prefer.
I'm also adding some features.
In this case, I'm adding
the common utility features
and the Python feature.
All of them are going to
install other tools as part
of the feature itself.
And remote user is the user
that is inside the container.
And it's connected to
the user on your laptop.
Okay.
So, as you see here, I'm starting from,
let's say, a vanilla VS code.
There's nothing in it except
the dev container extension.
Of course, otherwise it doesn't work.
And if we connect to the container now,
it will load this configuration
that has quite a big amount of settings.
And you will see popping up
on the left-hand side
some extension icons.
You see Python now
and also testing, right?
So, it's also running the commands
that you have seen before.
The post attach commands
and the on create commands,
just to be sure that, for example,
the licenses are up to
date with the packages
that we are using inside
this project, right.
As I have added the Python feature,
we are going to see that
the virtual environment
is loaded automatically.
And we should see now,
yeah, they are.
Here they are.
Some problems in this file.
So, I thought to have written a good file.
No, I hadn't.
So, we need to refactor this file.
Otherwise, the CICD pipeline would fail.
Because in the CICD pipeline,
we will have all the checks.
So, let's go and refactor this.
To refactor this, we need to add Amazon Q.
To add Amazon Q, we need
to add the extension.
So, if you don't remember the
extension ID, I don't, okay.
So, I just search Amazon Q.
And then you can simply do
add to devcontainer.json.
What it does is you will see down here.
Right?
So, you can dynamically
update the JSON file.
Then, do we want to use Amazon Q as it is?
No, we don't.
We want to add some context
to Amazon Q in order
to perform better.
To do that, we create an MD
file that is going to be used
as a rule for Amazon Q developer.
And we want to make it inside
the devcontainer, right?
So, we need to add it to
the .devcontainer directory.
And we also need,
I don't want to write it down.
So, I'm going to copy it.
Where is it?
Here.
So, we add this command
to the post create.
It does create the
.amazonq rules at the root
of the project.
It's a mandatory path, okay?
And then it copies the MD
file into that directory.
What do we have in the MD file?
So, we are setting just general rules.
We want to have all the
Python files with the header,
with the copyright and the license.
We want to have all the
functions with the doc string.
We want to have all the Python files
to be compliant with that page, right.
It's just an example.
You can add whatever you want.
Okay, so now we need to
rebuild the container in order
to have this inside the container.
So, we do rebuild container.
It's going to, let's
say, start from scratch
and rebuild the Docker image,
most probably cached, right?
And then install all the features,
run all the post create commands,
including the amazonq command.
And you see here,
it's going to rebuild
the Python environment.
It might take a while.
Did you save it?
Oh, damn it.
(Kris laughing)
- [Kris] That's a classic.
- [Matteo] It's not going
to solve all the problems.
Some problems are between the
chair and the laptop, right?
- [Kris] You're going
to need some help there.
- [Matteo] Yeah, right.
We'll just enable auto saving.
So conscious of time, I'm
going to comment this out.
Because as I said before,
it's important to create VM, right?
Or in this case, as we are starting
from the container already,
it's not mandatory to rebuild it.
So, I'm gonna-
- Save that one as well.
- [Matteo] I'm going to
rebuild the container.
It should take
less time.
Okay.
Thanks, Chris.
It's building.
Fantastic.
We will see that now it's going to run,
you see here,
the amazonq, the copy of amazonq
rules inside the directory.
And if we refresh, we
see amazonq here, right?
With the best practices file.
And also, we should see amazonq.
Fantastic.
We have amazonq.
We need to log in.
Let's log in.
Proceed to browser.
- [Kris] The key thing here
is that the dev container is kind
of independent from the repository.
So, you tie them two together,
and then the repository
gets whatever context
for amazonq you define
in that dev container inside the repo.
So, you can essentially define a context
and manage that context.
And that's really powerful.
- [Matteo] Okay.
So now we can refactor the|Python file.
So, let's ask amazonq to do that.
Refactor.
It's going to take the entire file.
And as a context,
we see that we have also
the best practices MD file.
And as you see here, I'm
having the new comments
at the top of the file, the new header.
And it's well formatted.
We have all the module doc strings.
Ready to go.
Most probably, the CICD
pipeline won't fail.
But
we have done it here, locally.
Inside this only container, right,
it doesn't scale.
We need to create this building block
that could be shared between people.
And to do that, we switch to features.
So, features are the building
blocks that can be packaged
and be shareable between
developers and teams,
between other dev containers at the end.
So, to do that,
we need to create a folder
inside dev container named
as the feature.
So that is going to be the feature name.
And as this is going to
take a while to build,
I'm going to do that.
One thing I want to highlight is that,
as you see here in the config file,
I've commented out the copy amazonq rules
that we used before.
So, we don't need that anymore.
As we don't need amazonq anymore,
because it's going to
be part of the feature.
So, I'm going to rebuild it,
including the local feature.
So, you can reference
local features this way.
You just provide a path.
And it's going to be included
inside the dev container.
So, let's switch here on the terminal.
I'm going to show you what files we need
to create a feature.
Essentially, we need two
files, at least two files.
One, it's named install.sh.
And by the way, these two files
need to be named this way.
Okay, it's important.
And the install.sh is just
an installation script
that will install the tool
you need, essentially.
In this case, it's going to
create the amazonq rules.
The other important file
is the dev container feature JSON, right.
This is the configuration
file for the feature.
It requires a semantic versioning.
You can use the same
blocks as you used inside
the devcontainer.json file
for the dev container itself.
So, for example, here I'm
installing the extension amazonq,
as we were doing before
inside the dev container.
And also, I'm moving
the amazonq rules inside the repository.
That's an important
thing, because otherwise,
when you create the container,
you create the rules.
But the repository is not mounted
inside the repository yet.
So, when it mounts inside,
it will override everything.
When you mount a file
system over a mount point,
if you have something in that mount point,
it won't be accessible anymore.
So, these are the two important things.
The two important files.
Let's see if it's built.
Oh yeah, it's built.
Perfect.
So now we see that we have
amazonq now here as part
of the repository.
And it's the new one.
I've added the label inside
the file of the feature.
You see here, this is
actually the same file
we have in the actual .amazonq rules file.
So, we have created finally the feature,
but it's still local.
So, this is the development
process to create a feature
that is going to be reusable afterwards.
To create the reusable feature,
we need to package and
create an image for that.
So, we have created a factory for that.
Kris will tell you more about it later.
And I want to show you one
thing that is, the last one,
and that is, let's say,
the outcome of that factory.
So, we have seen the dev
container config file,
the feature,
and if we condense everything together,
we create one image, right.
And that one image is this one.
So, you can think, I mentioned before,
about building blocks.
You can have dev containers, features,
you can put different things together,
and you can create one single image.
It's quite easy for a developer
to create an environment,
just creating the configuration
file with one line, right.
So, you can provide developers this thing.
As you see here, I'm starting again
from a plain VS Code project.
But I have this image
that is actually the union
of everything that we have seen today.
So, if we reopen that in the container,
it will check the config
file that has only the image,
only the image, right.
But it's going to create
everything for us.
We will see extensions.
We will see post create
commands, post attach commands,
Amazon Q, Amazon Q context, everything,
just with one line config.
So essentially, this is what
we usually do when we develop.
And Kris, over to you again.
- [Kris] Thank you, Matteo.
Before we do, please switch
the screen for me, okay.
So yeah, we're kind of approaching the end
of the session already.
But we want to leave you
with something more tangible.
Indeed, that container
that Matteo just pulled
in that was built remotely
with CodePipeline.
And this is a very high-level diagram.
So, we built a CDK pattern for a pipeline,
which is essentially a warehouse
with stateful resources,
and all these different
pipeline stacks per image
and per feature.
And the way this works is we
just copy a configuration,
or you copy a configuration onto S3.
That will trigger EventBridge,
kickstart the pipeline
for each image or feature
that you actually push to S3.
And that will deliver it to ECR.
And from that point on,
you can either then pull it
into your project like Matteo did,
or you can use Crane to bring
it over to your repository,
which is available to your
employees or your teammates.
Or you create this modular landscape
of a base container with
an extended container,
which uses that and
which brings in features
that you also have managed
by other teams or whatnot.
And that's a little bit how that is.
It's published on AWS Samples.
The QR code is on the other slide.
Is there any questions on this?
So, this is also a
multi-architecture image.
So, it builds it for
Mac and for PC, again,
using AMD64 and ARM with Graviton.
So, it'll run on all the machines.
- [Matteo] Maybe we can also
show how to create a feature
with that pipeline.
- [Kris] Oh, yeah.
Well, let's do that.
Do we use a recent package?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
So, as Kris mentioned,
we have created a repository
that is public on AWS Samples.
And there is an example for Kero CLI.
So, we have created the Kero CLI feature
that can be added to the dev container.
And let's do it together.
So, to do that, we need to
create a new folder here,
Kero CLI, and then
install SH.
Here we are going to put the
code to install Kero CLI.
So, what we usually do
when we develop features,
we understand how to install that package
that we want to do.
So, we go and check Kero.
We do it here.
CLI.
Oh, it's pretty easy.
So, we copy that single line.
But that single line is going to install
that with the root user.
We want to install that
with the remote user inside the container.
So, I'm not going to write
everything from scratch.
So, we have it already.
You have it already.
It's public.
So, we are going to add this code here.
Okay.
Let's create the other file,
dev container.feature.json.
And in here, we need
to put the config file.
So, this one, essentially.
Okay.
It's more readable here.
So, we define the name, the
ID, the semantic versioning,
the description, and
let's say a constraint.
So, it's going to be installed
after the other feature.
That if you remember well,
it's part of the dev
container config file.
So, we do this.
And to package everything up, we need to,
so here we are inside
the dev container folder.
We see the kiro-cli directory.
We go into there.
And we have those two files.
So, we need to zip this content
into a zip file.
And then we are going
to upload S3 API.
We are going to upload this
zip file into the S3 bucket
that Kris mentioned before that was part
of the architecture as an entry point.
So, this one is going to
be pushed to the S3 bucket.
This is the version ID.
And if we wait a bit,
it's going to be built by the pipeline.
We have created it already.
So, what we can do is
just add the feature,
features, and
I'm going to take this repository.
It's the same without the dictionary.
It's pretty difficult doing that here.
Okay.
Perfect.
What am I missing?
The comment.
- [Kris] You've got to change the name.
- [Matteo] Yes.
- [Kris] It's not a base image.
- Where.
- Saved.
- [Kris] Yes, saved.
Thank you, okay.
I need to change features and Kiro-CLI.
We name it this way, right.
So, we save again.
And we rebuild.
Okay, it might take a while.
But at the end, we are going
to have the same environment
as before with Kiro CLI installed.
So, we are going to check
that from the terminal
if it didn't do any typo.
Okay.
It's running the pip licenses
because we are building again.
And we are not just
attaching to the container.
Okay, come on.
In the meantime,
(speaker indistinct chattering)
if you have any questions, let's see.
Kiro CLI, we have it, right?
Loading the VM, Kiro-CLI, help.
Yeah, we have it.
Okay, so this is online on ECR.
And it can be shared with everyone.
Yeah, so this is really easy, right?
This does give you a
rather large container.
And you do need to look at
how Kiro actually looks.
I did this with Amazon
QDeveloper at first.
But it was an unstripped binary.
So, it was massive.
So yeah, this unlocks
really powerful patterns.
If you want to have pre-commit
hooks using Kiro as well,
or you want to use Kiro
to give you some insights
on just your commit messages,
you're doing changes
in a certain format, that's
how you can use this as well.
So yeah, thank you.
Awesome.
And then I promised the
last slide is also featuring
the QR code for that repo.
And yeah, I mean, you've got
a full week ahead of you.
So, make good use of it.
Enjoy your time here at reInvent.
(audience applauding)